ask you Jordan what is it that you love
about Michaela what would you
say she's pretty damn
funny she's tough man don't mess with
her she'll bite you and you'll remember
it she's a formidable person like my
wife like my son they're fun to be
around don't mess with them that's a
pretty good combination Michaela what
would you say about your dad why do you
love your dad he's incredibly
compassionate and open he cares deeply
about everything that's going on in
people's lives you've definitely have
more compassion for the average person
than I do I I kind of think come on
there you're a hard ass maybe maybe try
a little harder but that's that's not
what you think so I would say what I
love about him is his openness which has
led our family I mean to where it is now
I think is him saying yes to opportunity
and being open and compassionate